oui c'est pour moi c'est un très beau
cadeau ben je n'espérais pas le voir
aussitôt donc ouais je suis bien content
content parce que je sais que star wars
il faut vraiment fait la queue
pouvoir déplacer tout ça donc on est
très content d'être en avant première un
public ravi et privilégie ils sont plus
d'une centaine d'usagers du réseau car
jaune a assisté à cette projection
privée avec en avant première le dernier
opus de la saga star wars
le réseau car jaune fait en janvier 2016
ses 20 ans c'était pour nous au
département au service de communication
du département et service communication
du délégataire de marquer l'événement
nous avons pu négocier
l'exclusivité de ce
film
en présentation
en avant première à la réunion et dans
tous les pays du monde
donc pour nous c'était une occasion de
montrer au public réunionnais que le
réseau car jaune est un réseau dynamique
20 ans pour le réseau car jaune le
premier anniversaire pour le nouveau
réseau car jaune donc depuis le 11
décembre 2014
nous avons mis en place bien sûr un
tarif unique pour les lignes principales
nous avons mis en place la carte réunis
parce qu'une carte intéropérables donc
utilisable sur tous les réseaux de
transport interurbain et urbain pour la
première édition de l'opération ciné car
jaune
les voyageurs ont pu côtoyer dans les
bus et les gares routières de lille
les personnages de la saga ils pouvaient
ensuite participé à un jeu en ligne et
gagner des places pour l'avant-première
40k organiser le jeu et je fonce il faut
les jouer un jeu de piano il fallait
refaire ma musique qui faisait et puis
sur jacky gagner ben c'est bon j'ai joué
en jeu sur internet
pour fêter les 20 ans du réseau car
jaune et le lancement de leur nouveau
site internet l'organisation voulait
offrir à ses usagers un événement unique
le septième volet de la saga star wars
le réveil de la force en avant premier
ses proches ses amis ravis téléphone
était attendue depuis longtemps mais pas
déçu youtube
non ça va franchement bon film et attend
la suite merci car jeunes la cible